the thought that it was time to
seek sleep but was awake I wanted to
put down the volume that I thought I
still had in my hands out of breath way
I had not stopped while sleeping to
make reflections on what I had just
read but these reflections  had taken
a rather particular turn it seemed to me
that I was myself what
louvre was talking about age a church a quartet the
rivalry between françois 1er and charles
quint this belief survive for a
few seconds
when I wake up she would not know my
reason but  weigh like scales on
my eyes and prevent them from
realizing that the candlestick had not arrived
then it began to become unintelligible to me that
after the metempsychosis
the thoughts of a previous existence
the subject of the book detach from me
I was  free to apply me or not as
soon as I regain my sight and I was
very surprised to find around me
a soft and restful darkness for
my eyes and perhaps even more so for me.  r
my mind to which it appeared like
a thing without incomprehensible cause
like a really obscure thing I
wondered what time they could
be I heard the whistle of
trains that more or less a
distant colleague like the song of a bird in
a forest  reselling the distances
describe to me the expanse of the
deserted countryside where the traveler hastens towards the
next station and the little path that
follows will be engraved in his memory
by the excitement he owes
again to unaccustomed art to the
recent talk and  to the farewells under the
foreign language which still follow him
in the silence of the night to the approaching softness
of the return I pressed
tenderly but cheek against the belgians
of the pillow which pleases but fresh
are like the cheeks of our in france
I rubbed a  match to look at
my watch
almost midnight
it's the moment the patient who was
forced to go on a trip and had to
sleep in another case the stranger
woke up by  r a crisis rejoices when he
sees under the door
a r two days what happiness it is
already morning in a moment the
servants will be up he will be able to
ring the bell they will come to help him
the hope of being relieved gives him
courage to suffer
he just thought he heard footsteps the
pines approach then move away and
the day stoppage that was under his
door has disappeared céline lis we come from the
executives the gas the last servant has
left we will have to stay all night to
suffer without remedy
I realize I was asleep and sometimes
I only had two strokes left to dream for a
moment long enough to hear the
organic creaking of the woodwork
to open my eyes to stare at the case
and score from the darkness to taste thanks
to a  momentary glimmer of consciousness the
summit or and mop the furniture the
bedroom
the whole of which I was only a small
part is to the insensitivity of which I
returned quickly to provide either one sleeps
eats had joined his
swimming fort forever  s bygone of my primitive life to
rediscover such childish terrors
as that which my great
uncle matter apart from my curls etc.
had dissipated the date day for me
of a new era where they had cut off I
am going to suffer this event during my
sleep people you  find the memory as
soon as i had managed to wake up
to escape the hands of my great
uncle but as a precaution
jean tourret completely my head from my
pillow before returning to the
world of dreams
sometimes as eve was born from a rib
of  adam
a woman injured in my sleep
from a false position of my thigh formed
from the pleasure that I was about to the
side I imagined that it was she who offered it to
me my body that felt
in hers my own  heat lets you
join it I put watching the rest of the humans seemed to
me to be very far
away from this woman that
I had left just a few
moments ago majou was still hot
from her bay  ser my body koba would kill by
the weight of her size
if, as sometimes happens, she
had the features of a woman I had
known in life I was going to give myself
this goal entirely to find like
those who go on a trip  to see with
their eyes a desired city and
imagine that one can cost in
reality
the chariot of the dream little a little his memory
fades away and I had forgotten the
daughter of death
a sleeping man stands in a circle
around  him the thread of the works the order of the
years and of the worlds and consults them
of instance and lyon is
and there in a second the point of the
earth that they occupy the time which has
passed until his awakening
but  the round can week and will be
that towards the morning after some
insomnia the sleep take him
reading in a posture too
different from that gildor
usually it is enough dark
lifted to stop and make the sun go back
and at the first minute his
awakening  he won't be there anymore  the hour he
will estimate warns about going to bed
that if he dozes off in an
even more downgraded divergent position
for example after dinner sitting in an
armchair then the upheaval will be
complete in the worlds deorbiting the
magic armchair will make him travel at full
speed  in time and in space
and at the moment of opening the eyelids it
is believed to sleep a few months
earlier in another country but it was
enough that in my very bed we
are it was deep and relaxed
completely in spirit then this one  here
is the plan of the place where I had
fallen asleep and when I put awake in the
middle of the night as
I did not know where I was I did not even know at the
first moments who I was I
only had in its first simplicity  the
feeling of existence as it can
quiver in the depths of an animal I was more
destitute than the caveman but
then the
golden memory not yet of the place where I was but of
some of those I had  s inhabited
and you I could have come to me
like help from above to pull me out
of the nothingness
from which I could not have emerged on my own I
thought without a second over
centuries of civilization and the image
Confusedly interview of kerosene lamps
then of shirts with folded down shirts
recomposed little by little the
original features of my self perhaps
the immobility of things around us
the hour is it amused by our
certainty that it is them and not to
d  Others by the immobility of our
thoughts always silenced it is it
that when I woke up like this my
mind was agitated to seek without
succeeding in knowing where I was everything
revolved around me in the darkness
the things
the countries  the years my body too much for
10 to move seek according to the form
of its fatigue to repair the position of
its members to induce the direction
of the wall the place of the furniture to
rebuild and to name the dwelling
where it was its memory the  memory
of his  ribs of his knees of his
shoulders present to him successively
several of the rooms where he had slept
while around him the walls a v6
changing place according to the shape of the
imaginary room swirl in the
darkness and even before my thought which
hesitates and  where the threshold of times and
forms and identify the home by
comparing the circumstances him my
body to remember for each one the type
of bed the place of the doors
the opening of the windows
the existence of a corridor with the thought
that I had  desire while sleeping and when I
woke up I found my ankylosed side
trying to guess its orientation,
for example imagining myself lying facing the
wall in a large four-poster bed and
immediately I said to myself I ended up
falling asleep no matter what mum was  I did
n't come to say good evening
I was in the country at my
grandfather's who had been dead for many years
and my body
the side on which the game rested,
fritel guardian of a past that my mind
should never have forgotten  I remember
the flame of the bohemian glass nightlight
in the shape of a turn suspended from the
ceiling by chains the sienna
marble fireplace in my
bedroom two colleagues at
my grandparents in distant days
that at this moment I am  appeared current
without representing them to me exactly and
that I will see better later
when I am completely awake